wir schauen auf ein wirklich ganz
schreckliches bade drama in aachen zwei
drittel jungs in naturfreibad am rursee
die beiden sieben und neun jahre alten
kinder die baden hier sie kommen aus
großbritannien sind hier wohl nur zu
besuch am abend aber sind sie dann
plötzlich weg polizei thw dlrg alle
suchen nach ihnen finden sie dann auch
schließlich im wasser sie werden
geborgen und reanimiert und trotz aller
rettungsversuche sterben beide kinder
später im krankenhaus
und jetzt bei bild live dazu zu diesem
schrecklichen bade drama mit zwei toten
jungs sieben und neun jahre alt martin
holz hause vom dlrg ich grüße sie
herzlich herholz hause wenn sie jetzt
von diesem neuen badeunfall hören zwei
tote jungen sieben und neun jahre alt
was geht ihnen da als erstes durch den
kopf ja es ist furchtbar und gerade dass
wir das immer wieder erleben also wir
sind jetzt im august und wir haben in
diesem jahr schon mehrere dieser
dramatischen fälle erleben müssen und
auch jahr für jahr wieder und jeder
falls es ist einfach schrecklich als ich
bin auch selbst mutter von zwei relativ
kleinen kindern ich habe auch immer die
sorge wenn sie allein am see oder am
meer spiel ab wann ab welchem alter kann
man die kinder denn auch wirklich mal
kurz aus den augen lassen selbst wenn
sie schwimmen können das ist ja immer
noch keine garantie oder was haben sie
für für tipps für alle eltern die
natürlich auch immer wieder besorgt sind
wenn kinder in der nähe von wasser sind
also ganz wichtig ist sicher dass man
einmal das bewusstsein dafür hat überall
dort wo wasser ist und kinder die auch
gerade wenn sie nicht schwimmen können
dass das eine gefahrenquelle ist dass
man darauf dass man da aufpassen muss
und gerade kinder die nicht schwimmer
sind die müssen auch eltern von ihren
eltern immer beaufsichtigt werden und
auch in griffweite bleiben das ist
sicherlich dass ein und dann hängt es
sehr viel von den von den gewässern ab
also im schwimmbad ist es natürlich eine
andere situation als in einem badesee
oder im meer auch da muss man sich
gedanken machen wo sind jetzt hier
mögliche gefahren worauf muss ich achten
und ja möglichst immer achtsam bleiben
und die gefahr auch kopfball
riesenproblem ist ja die korona zeit
gewesen dazu keine schwimmkurse zwei
jahre lang eine gefahr für viele viele
kinder jetzt ja ganz oft erkennen sie so
was wie corona badete man
kann den zusammenhang in der regel nicht
direkt herstellen aber wir denken schon
dass durch die korona pandemie zwei
jahre lang die menschen einfach jetzt
sehr weniger schwimmen konnten ich bin
mir da waren dazu im winter lief da
nicht viel mit bewegungen im wasser und
das wirkt sich dann schon natürlich auch
auf die fitness aus wenn daneben die
sommerzeit beginnt die menschen wieder
baden gehen das betrifft es nicht
unbedingt nur kinder und jugendliche
sondern menschen einen menschen ein
altersklassen also auch gerade ältere
wohl aber zum beispiel die das ganze
jahr über nicht schwimmen waren und
jetzt im sommer vielleicht der meinung
sind wieder zu weit raus zu spinnen
martin rolshausen von der dlrg besten
dank für ihre einschätzung
[Musik]